[موسيقى]
هاجم لص بسكينه رجلا في شارع مظلم سرعان
ما استسلم دون ان يتفوه بكلمه شرع قاطع
الطريق بسلب مال الرجل وساعته وكل ما يحمل
الى ان وجد تحت حزامهم مسدسا حربيا ومن
العيار الثقيل فانتزعه بخفه لينطق الرجل
اخيرا خذ كل ما تشاء ارجوك لكنني اتوسل
اليك ان تترك لي هذا المسدس واسحب
الرصاصات منه ان شئت وماذا ينفعك اذ ذاك
سال البلطجي فاجاب الخاضع احتفظوا به من
اجل وقت الشده فرد اللص المحترف وهل هناك
شده اشد من هذا الموقف يبنى عنيتره
الى العناوين
مرزوق الغانم يكشف وصيه للشيخ صباح لن
اقابل ربي وعلى يدي مصافحه لاسرائيليين
مجزره مدينه انسي ليست ارهابيه
فمنفذها ليس مسلما سنيا تعلق مجله المجله
تبون يعيد مقطعا يتوعد فرنسا بيوم الحساب
الى النشيد الوطني الجزائري
قوانين اللجوء الاوروبي ارحم على اللاجئين
من قوانين الدول الاسلاميه
فجر السعيد ياسمين عز ونضال الاحمديه
يتنافسن على ترند الجدل والشوكولا مو
يتصدر
فاحشه علنيه على شاطئ بيروت العمومي لم
تستدعي اعتصاما نسويا ولا ذكوريا يطالب
بالحياء العام
هاله سرحان تتخطى نفسها التهاب القرش
سائحا روسيا عمل مدبر ضد مصر
مدرسه اردنيه تتدخل في حياه المعلمات
الزوجيه
وتمنعهن من الحمل والولاده
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في مثل هذا اليوم السادس عشر من
يونيو حزيران ولد عام
1934 الشيخ الراحل صباح الاحمد الجابر
الصباح الامير الخامس عشر لدوله الكويت
الشيخ صباح الذي قاد بلاده في مرحله مهمه
من نهضتها لعب ايضا دور الاطفائي للفتن
والحروب على المستوى القومي العربي وكان
شخصيه مرموقه على المسرح الدولي للمناسبه
استذكر رئيس مجلس الامه الكويتيه السابق
مرزوق الغانم محطه فاصله مورس خلالها ضغط
خارجي كبير على الامير الهادئ لعقد
اتفاقيه مع اسرائيل لكن طبعه غلب التطبيع
واتخذ موقفا يشبه الوصيه للعرب ان ذلك
خلقه قال لي قال لي شوف يا ولدي لقد بلغت
من العمر اتياح المفرداته
وانا ما ابي اقابل ربي
وانا
مصافح
رحل الشيخ صباح وبقيت مبادئه ثابته في
الكويت حيال فلسطين كذلك بقيت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ثابته في برامجها
المفتوحه على الجرائم جرائم قتل المدنيين
في فلسطين دون ان تميز رصاصاتها بين صغير
وكبير جنود الاحتلال مصحوبين بكميه من
المستوطنين اعتدوا على الاهالي والاطفال
في مدينه القدس المحتله واعتقلوا طفلين
كذلك اعتقلوا ثلاثه شبان من المعتصمين
دعما لعائله صب لبن في البلده القديمه
بالقدس ضد قرار اقتلاعها من دارها العتيقه
نبقى في اخبار مجازر الاطفال ونتحول الى
فرنسا التي نجاها الله تعالى من مجزره
ارهابيه تتعطس لدماء الاطفال
المجزره ارتكبت بكامل اركانها لكن الله
سترى المسلمين بان كان المجرم مسيحيا
متدينا من اللاجئين السوريين لا يوجد اي
دافع ارهابي تؤكد النائبه العامه لمدينه
انسي مسرح الجريمه في قلب مدينه انسي هجم
رجل مسلح بسكين اطفالا في ملعب في هذه
الحديقه المتاخمه للبحيره سرق الرجل مرتين
باسم يسوع المسيح باللغه الانجليزيه خلال
الهجوم اصب وتم اعتقاله عده فصول مدرسيه
كانت في نزهه في الحديقه وقت الهجوم الذي
لم يكن له اي طبع ارهابي حسب النائبه
العامه الفرنسيه لم يتحدد الدافع بعد
يوجد اي دافع ارهابي واضح تحت عنوان
للارهاب دين وطائفه ايضا نشرت مجله المجله
السعوديه مقالا جاء فيه بعد ايام من حديث
وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه عن ان الخطر الاول
الذي يهدد فرنسا واوروبا هو الارهاب السني
سجلت جريمه عبد المسيح في انس الفرنسية
التي كلما وقعت جريمه تشبهها في فرنسا
سارع السياسيون والاعلام الى وصفها
بالارهاب فان ظهر ان الفاعل ليس مسلما
سنيا بدا الحديث عن تبريرات وعن دوافع
اخرى للجريمه ماذا ينقل مراسل الجزيره
محمد البقالي عن مسلمي فرنسا كان يحمل
وفقا لشهود عيان صليبا
وانجيلا اثناء محاولته او اثناء هجومه على
هؤلاء الذين صادفهم في طريقه
وبالتالي فالشخص وطبيعته وديانته واسمه
عبد المسيح كل هذا اربك السلطات الفرنسيه
على مستوى تصنيف العمليه لانه دعني يقول
دعيني اقول ازدهار بانه لم يسبق في فرنسا
ان تم تصنيف اي عمليه او اي هجوم لم ينفذه
مسلم على انه ارهابي بغض النظر عن طبيعه
الهجوم حتى ان كثيرا كثيرا من المسلمين
هنا يتساءلون هل اصبح من شرط تصنيف
العمليه على انها ارهابيه ان يكون المنفذ
مسلم الديانه شبكه مونتي كارلو الدوليه
الفرنسيه تحدثت عن تسرع بعض السياسيين من
اليمين واليمين المتطرف لاستثمار مذبحه
الاطفال ضمن سياساتهم العنصريه واورد
التغريده للناشط السياسي المتطرف جام
مسيحه
وهو فرنسي من اصل مصري يلمح فيها الى ان
الجاني جهادي اسلامي وبعد الاعلان عن
ديانه المعتدي حذف تغريدته بصمت رفض
الانصياع لاوامر الشرطه بالتوقف بعد طعنه
لاخر رجل ملقى كما نرى على الارض ليتم
القاء القبض عليه اخيرا
فيهتف باسم المسيح مرتين باللغه
الانجليزيه
دقائق معدودات قام فيها بطعن عده اطفال
ومتقاعدين في هذا المنتزه بمدينه انسي
اسمه عبد المسيح ذو واحد وثلاثين سنه ابو
لطفل يبلغ ثلاثه اعوام حاصل على لجوء في
السويد وغير معروف لدى الاجهزه الامنيه
زوجته السابقه مصدومه كثيرا بسبب عدم
حصوله على الجنسيه السويديه قرر مغادره
البلاد انفصلنا لانني رفضت الذهاب معه
اتصل بي قبل اربعه اشهر وقال لي انه يعيش
داخل كنيسه فرنسا ملحاحه في الشكوى من
الاخرين وفي نفس الوقت لا تبذل جهدا كافيا
لاصلاح علاقاتها مع الاخرين يعني كيف
يستقيم تمسك باريس بجماجم ضحاياها
الجزائريين تتباهى بعرضها فيما يسمى بمتحف
الانسان ثم تنزعج من قرار الرئيس الجزائري
عبد المجيد تبون باعاده المقطع من النشيد
الوطني الذي يتوعد فرنسا بيوم الحساب
[موسيقى]
الكتاب
لدي
[موسيقى]
الاتحاد الاوروبي فعل هذا الاسبوع من
الفضيله ما لم تفعله منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي او جامعه الدول العربيه
فاقر قوانين اللجوء جديده تفرض غرامه على
الدول الاوروبيه التي لا تستقبل اللاجئين
ومعلوم ان قسما كبيرا من مقدمي طلبات
اللجوء الى اوروبا مسلمون
رغم معارضه دول كالمجر وبولندا وتحفظ دول
كالمانيا اقر مجلس الوزراء الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالاجماع قوانين جديده للجوء الى
التكتل فقد تم الاتفاق على انشاء مراكز
استقبال للاجئين على الحدود الخارجيه
للاتحاد بحيث يتسنى لمن يريد تقديم طلب
اللجوء بالتسجيل في احد هذه المراكز ويتم
النظر اذا ما كان يحق له المتابعه
باجراءات اللجوء او رفض طلبه في مده
تتراوح ما بين 12 اسبوعا الى سته اشهر
ويتضمن القرار فرض غرامه 20 الف يورو عن
كل شخص ترفض دوله ما استقباله فيما يجري
توطين طالب اللجوء في هذه الحاله في دوله
اخرى
ملايين المسلمين يتمنون العيش في اوروبا
او في معتقدات قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان بحسب مستشارها يعقوب نورين الذي
يقول ان الاسير لدينا
يتمنى ان يكون اسيرا طول عمره اي اسير
عندنا نحن يتمنى ان يكون اسيرا طول عمره
الاسرى عندنا يتم تعامل معهم بطريقه راقيه
بطريقه تحت نحن عندنا وحده كامله لحقوق
الانسان
معتمده في جنيف
[موسيقى]
شغلت الترند العربي خلال الايام الاخيره
ثلاث نساء بكلام يذكرنا بالحديث النبوي
الشريف من كان يؤمن بالله واليوم الاخر
فليقل خيرا او ليصمت لكن فجر السعيد تقول
انها لا تريد ان تصمت عن حقها وهذا حقها
بعد ان رفض لبنان استقبالها فاتهمت حزب
الله بالوقوف وراء القرار مؤكده ان جواز
سفرها الكويتي لا يحمل اي ختم اسرائيلي
لكن البعض اعتبر ان مواقفها بحد ذاتها
تحمل ترويجا لثقافه الهزيمه ودعوه دائمه
للتطبيع مع اسرائيل التي تحتل ارضا
لبنانيه وفلسطينيه وسوريه وهل انت من
مؤيدي السلام مع اسرائيل
اكيد اكيد وشرحت وجهه نظري الاف المرات ان
احنا جربنا الحرب معاهم ولا نكسب في
المرتبه الثانيه لنساء الترند حلت ياسمين
عز المذيعه التي تشتري الشهره بالاساءه
الى المراه وهذه المره المراه اللبنانيه
اذا انت سيده لبنانيه جميله هتقول لجوزك
يا فينيقي هاي حياتي هاي فينيقي
منها فينيقي اللي هو فينيقك انت للملكيه
ومنها في نيقي نسبه للحضاره الفينيقيه انت
عايشه طول عمرك بتاكليه تبوله وفتوشه
ومنقوشه انسي بقى الكلام ده خالص من هنا
ورايح هتاكليه تبول وفتوش ومنقوش الغي
التاء المربوطه من حياتك يا مدام ملهاش اي
لازمه في اخر الكلام حتى اتقي المربوطه
تخنقك قلوه في الردود من الشباب والشابات
ملات الشاشات والحسابات والجامع بينها
تاكيد اللبنانيين على العشق اللافت لمصر
التي لا يؤاخذونها بما فعلته ياسمين منها
وبنحكي فيه بالتفصيل شو صاير ولكن هذا
الحقد وقتها كونوا اكيدين انه الياسمين
راح بصير شوك والعز راح يتحول لذل اما عن
الفتوش والمنقوش فنحن مبسوطين فيهم كثير
كثير ويلي مش عاجبه ما ياكل هالقد ببساطه
انا مثلا ما بحب الكشري ولكن بحب منظر
الكشري وبحب اسم الكشري وبحب يلي بيعمل
الكشري وبحب كل مصري بحب الكشري يا جماعه
هيدي مصر ست الدنيا وتاج راسنا وهو شعب
مصر اخواتنا وحبايبنا للمرتبه الاولى
الترندل حلت الصحفيه اللبنانيه الاشكاليه
نضال الاحمديه التي اتهمت بتحقير السوريين
لان عاملا منهم في لبنان لم يعرف معنى
الشوكولامو
هو نوع من الايس كريم ومش كثير طيب
بالمناسبه بوظه الدق العربي بسوق الحميديه
بدمشق اطيب منه بكثير ليلي بيعرف بالاصاله
الشاميه لا بيعرفوا ولا جود مورنينج وكل
شيء بالطب معربينه حتى يعني البنسلين
بكتبوها بالعربي عم بقولوا
شو قلت له والله ما بعرف بعدها مش مترجم
بالعربي لازم يرجع بالقوه يعني ثلاثه
مليون سوري بدهم يقعدوا بلبنان الا اذا
عملوا لهم دوله في اختلاف كبير بالسقافات
عم بقول لك ما بنعرف نتفاهم على بعض بخاف
يترك باريس الشرق ويرجع على سوريا لانه
لما شاف لبنان ما صدق انه هو بقعد مع
لبنانيه اللي عم بيتعلموا يقولوا بونجور
يعني صباح الخير ما بقت تعجبهم هل تعرفون
لماذا لقب لبنان سابقا بسويسرا الشرق لانه
كان المركز الماليه للشرق الاوسط
بقوانينها تشبه تلك المطبقه في سويسرا اما
اليوم فقط صار لبنان بفضل منظومته الحاكمه
مغالط علي بابا الشرق التي تسرق ودائع
ابنائها في البنوك بس نحن اللبنانيه بنعرف
نقول كتير منيح بونجور وبونسوار الا يكفي
شوكولا مو تتسبب باغلاق حسابين نضال
الاحمدي على تويتر وانستجرام
هالكلمه اللي فجاه صارت واحده من اشهر
الكلمات المتداوله حاليا فمين كان يفكر
انه حاجتك شوكولا مو على تيك توك يوصل ل23
مليون مشاهده في اختلاف كبير بالسقافات
وهالكلام ما مر مرور الكرام عند السوريين
ومنهم النجوم اللي ردوا على كلام نضال
ابرزهم معتصم النهار واللي رفعت عليه نضال
دعوه قدح وذنب بعدما رد على تصريحاتها
وكتب عليكم قبل كل شيء بالمحطات والاذاعات
والاعلاميين الذين يستضيفون هذه انهم على
علم التام بانها سوف تسيء لشعب كامل
صدقوني ومع ذلك يقومون باستضافتها وفتح
الهواء لها لحصل ترند ومن ثم
يتهربون من المسؤوليه بحجه انه رايها
الخاص شركاء معها هناك سوري واحد تؤيده
النضال على الحلوى والمره من هو 2011 قياد
تعرف انا شو عملت اول لبنانيه قالت نعمله
بشار الاسد لم يسقط بشار الاسد انا مع
رئيس الاسد تذكرون الضجه الكبرى التي
اثيرت قبل اسابيع قليله في لبنان بسبب
قرار بلديه صيدا الزام رواد شاطئها العام
بالاحتشام وعدم ادخال الخمور وقد قوبل
القرار بتظاهره نسويه نقلتها وسائل
الاعلام المحليه مباشره على الهواء في
حينه ووجه الرئيس احد الاحزاب سؤالا حول
الموضوع للحكومه سجلت هذا الاسبوع حادثه
مهينه للمراه وللرجل على حد سواء تمثلت
بمعاشره جنسيه مكشوفه وبشكل علني على شاطئ
الرمل البيضه في بيروت صور احدهم الحادثه
لينتشر الفيديو كندار في الهشيم لكننا لم
نسمع عن اعتصام النسوي او ذكوري يطالب
التزام بادنى درجات الحياه العام ولا عن
اسئله احزاب للحكومه حول تقصيرها في ضبط
القانون والاخلاق على الشواطئ العامه
وقالت اداره المسبح في بيانها انما كان
الفاحشه يبعد 600 متر تقريبا عن موقع
واداره المسبح المجاني العمومي وان مصور
الفيديو كان متواجدا داخل احد المقاهي في
المنطقه المقطع المذكور اثار غضب واستياء
رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وطلب
السلطات اللبنانيه بضروره اعتقال المانيين
وتقديمهم القضاء في اسرع وقت ممكن
خبر التهام سمك القرش سائحا روسيا في
الغردقه بمصر كان صادما لكن الصدمه كانت
اعنف في قلم هاله سرحان التي اتهمت جهات
لم تسميها بارسال سمك القرش الى الشواطئ
المصريه الابتلاع ما تيسر من السياح
الاجانب وضرب موسم السياحه في مصر
المحروسه من المكائد والمؤامرات تضيفها له
يلي مع تغريدتها مش حتقدر تصدق عينيك
الصور مرعبه لن ننشرها في مدينه الغردقه
الساحليه المطله على البحر الاحمر وبينما
كان يسبح فوج من السياح الروس انقضت عليهم
سمكه قرش التهمت شخصا واصابت اثنين اخرين
الصيادون سارعوا بصيد سمكه القرش هذه
تعرضت سمكه القرش للضرب من قبل الصيادين
الغاضبين الذين صاحوا ان هذا هو القرش
الذي اكل
سمكه القرش بداخلها نصف جسد السائح الروسي
السلطات استخرجت نصف الجثه من داخل القرش
وجاري البحث عن النصف الاخر يقول المثل
الروسي غني بخيل افقر من متسول قصتنا
الغريبه تجمع بين الغنى والبخل والتسول
متسوله مصريه عجوز توفيت هذا الاسبوع
ليكتشف ذبوها وجيرانها انها كانت مليونيرا
ولما ماتت اهل القريه واخواتها جمعولها
تمن الدفنه وكده اكتشفوا بقى بعد ما ماتت
دخلوا بيتها الاوضه اللي هي عايشه فيها
لقوا مليون جنيه فك
مليون جنيه فكه كوينات وخمسات وعشرات
وعشرينات زي ما حضراتكم شايفين في الصوره
مليون جنيه وفي الاخر ماتت ما استخدمتهمش
يعني بيقولوا حتى فلوس
الكنزي للنزهى يقول عباس محمود العقاد ان
الوظيفه هي عبوديه القرن العشرين اما في
القرن الواحد والعشرين فقد صارت العبوديه
ديجيتال مع سهوله تتبع انفاس الموظف وظله
حتى لو كان في غرفه نومه مدرسه اردنيه
خاصه تمنع المعلمات من الحمل والولاده
خلال السنه الدراسيه فهل تقيم المدرسه
لمعلماتها سكنا داخليا كي لا تضطر الى
منحهن اجازات ولاده وامومه
انتشرت صوره لكتاب من مدرسه خاصه ارسل الى
المعلمات العاملات فيها طالبت فيه بضروره
تنسيق الانجاب خلال اشهر العطله الصيفيه
وجاء في النص بما تقتضيه مصلحه العمل يرجى
الاخذ بعين الاعتبار بضروره تنظيم الحمل
بحيث تكون الولاده خلال عطله الصيف هذا
دفع وزاره التربيه والتعليم الاردنيه الى
التعليق فورا مؤكده بشكل رسمي رفضها لهذا
الكتاب الصادر عن المدرسه الخاصه واكدت ان
فريقا من اداره التعليم الخاص سيزور
المدرسه لاتخاذ الاجراءات المناسبه بحقها
اخيرا تفوق الدول عده في تكنولوجيا الحروب
المدمره التي لا تعتمد على فروسيه
المحاربين
لكن ما هو وجه الشبه بين بعض عسكري اوروبا
والشوكولا
كلاهما يتجمدان في البرد ويذوبان في الحر
يعلق مغردون بينما كان الرئيس الفرنسي يهم
بالتقاط الصوره التذكاريه مع ضيفه رئيس
مدغشقر خر حارس من فرقه قصر الاليزي على
الارض مغشيا عليه بسبب وصول الحراره في
باريس الى 30 درجه مئويه فقط ونحن هون لما
بتصير درجه الحراره 30 بنقعد بره
جنود الحرس الملكي البريطاني بثيابهم
مستقيله ايضا لم يكونوا اكثر صلابه من
جيرانهم الفرنسيين فقد اغمي على ثلاثه
منهم خلال تجربه لعرض عسكري سيقام احتفالا
بعيد ميلاد الملك
[موسيقى]
ختاما كان الديكتاتور في عصور غابره يطعم
رعيته بالقدر الذي يساعدها على النوم وكان
يكتفي بخمسين الى ستين بالمئه من مقدرات
البلاد له ولبطانته وكانت قسوته تغلف بشيء
من التعقل عندما ينازعه احد على السلطه
اما الديكتاتور الجديد فهو الاب المعظم
وانت ومالك لابيه من نبوغ سيادته توضع
المعادلات الصعبه في السلم وفي الحرب في
المال والعلم والعمل والفن من جذع دماغه
يشرق المستقبل ومن وجه مخيخه تقرا الايام
ان الدوله والدوله انا قالها الملك لويس
الرابع عشر ايام استبداد الزمن الجميل اما
في ازمنه الحكم المر فالتاريخ انا وانا
التاريخ الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
والحمراء
والصفراء والخضراء
انا الزعيم
المستديم انا الزعيم
[موسيقى]